Now, it would be great to see for
yourself that these embeddings
are clustering together as you'd expect.
One way to see it,
is by doing a nearest neighbor lookup
of the words that are closest
to any given word.
Another way is to try to reduce the
dimensionality of the embedding space
down to two dimensions, and to plug
the two dimensional representation.
If you do that the native way, for
example using PCA,
you basically get a mush.
You lose too much
information in the process.
What you need is a way of projecting
that preserves the neighborhood
structure of your data.
Things that are close in the embedding
space should remain close to the ends,
things that are far should
be far away from each other.
One very effective technique that
does exactly that is called t-SNE.
You'll get to play with this
visualization technique in
the assignment